hi guys welcome to the just pearly songs
youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to bad
boy
by juice world featuring young thug this
was a request
on my instagram do not forget to follow
me on instagram the link to my instagram
is in the description
i do polls i take requests for songs
that's literally
how i figure out what songs i'm gonna
react to it's on instagram
on top of that do not forget to
subscribe subscribe
subscribe you guys already know i'm
trying to move out someday and
every subscriber literally helps so much
so
if you guys could could subscribe i
would appreciate
appreciate it i can't talk today also
leave a comment
and let me know did i get the analysis
right
did i get it wrong i'll never know until
you guys let me know
anyways i'm rambling i'm rambling i'm
gonna start the video now you guys ready
i think you're ready sure that you know
that we're all human beings we all on
the same earth
so with that being said you can achieve
anything if not more than what
oh yeah that's a great message
okay
popping my head bopping my head i
already think i like the song
i'm bopping martin lawrence i'm a bad
boy
[Music]
okay he said will smith and martin
lawrence i don't know who martin
lawrence is
lawrence is but will smith like i don't
think he's a bad guy
and then he says went and got off my ass
and got the cash and got
in my bag boy i think that's a great
message
like i think this is a very motivational
song and he's telling people to really
go after their dreams
[Music]
i've been trapping all these birds i
think oh my gosh that's clever that's
clever
i've been trapping these birds so i
think a bird is like a snitch or like
someone who like talks bad about you
and he's been trapping them so he's
saying like as in hunting
trapping but also trapping like
okay i don't know what trapping actually
means but i know they use it in a lot of
like rap songs
so it's it's a word it means something
and he's using it as like a double
meaning
that's clever
[Music]
that's also clever overseas i'm getting
hundreds
[ __ ] croissants so he's saying he's
getting money overseas
and croissants like that's a win-win if
you ask me
[Music]
okay so they're they're jamming like
they got a nice car going on
black and white background um
he's saying that he got he is a good car
cooling level
okay i'm gonna do the dash get to the
bag
ain't no one as bad as me so
i don't know what do the dash means i
don't know maybe he's like chasing after
the bag
so i think he's just saying like i'm
gonna work hard and get money
that is a great message a great message
this is maybe one of my favorite songs
so far
[Music]
but he also is putting at the end you
better watch the way you breathe around
me because that'll be your last breath
so
there is a threat in there he is
threatening them
but he's just saying you better watch
the way you act
otherwise it's over for you
okay
[Music]
so he's saying newborn baby my rich
richard millie nine months he's saying
that he's got a newborn
baby and i is his name richard i don't
know but i think he's got a new kid
yeah i wouldn't talk to you either if
you shot at my mom
like i don't is he surprised
that's clever you got barbecue your
[ __ ] i'm so
fried and they crispy so he's saying i'm
so high and they're crispy is he saying
like your [ __ ] are ugly
that's my guess
[Music]
okay um i'm just being real with you i'm
just being blind he's just saying
he's just trying to be honest and that's
a good message like
that's a good message
okay so when he says i bust on her chest
i'm in a mess so he's saying
that after intercourse he
busted you know what that means on her
chest and he made a mess that's that's
the point of that
i got the neck
okay he said all right be the best
i got the neck ah i want to say
like i don't know what the neck means i
got the neck
i've heard rappers say that before so i
know it has a meaning but i don't
i got the net like you got is there
something on your neck
like doesn't mean i got money okay
whatever yeah i'm sure someone will let
me know in the comments i can turn a
check
and live like project act so he's saying
he's got money and he can party all the
time
[Music]
clever great chorus as usual
[Music]
i like it honestly
okay so this song
i enjoyed it this is probably my i'm
gonna give this one a 10. this was a
great song
like i thought it had a good message um
i mean there's a little a little bit of
talking about like
other girls a little bit of talking like
threats but not nothing big
the main message of the song was like
chase after your dreams
and i have money now but i like anyone
can do it chase after your dreams
i think that's a great message i felt
like i could shimmy i felt like i could
bop so this song
is my first i've never done a 10 before
but it's getting a 10.
anyways let me know in the comments is
my interpretation right
is it wrong do not forget to subscribe
i'm so tired of half of you
like you watch my content subscribe like
help a girl out and leave a like leave a
like
i'ma talk to you guys next time